men can never understand why females can
have male friends but we tend to believe
that we can have male friends and the
reason why we kind of think like this is
because we would rather have a friend
who secretly loves us than a female
friend that secretly hates us usually
when men don't like each other they
separate from each other women when they
don't like each other they'll make
reservations together and they'll still
keep in each other's lives for men if
they play a sport together they can
pretty much be friends for us you can do
everything right with a female
friendship all it takes is a birthday
gone wrong or a boyfriend that they
don't like and the entire friendship is
destroyed and there's a safety in a male
friendship that we can't find in female
friendships because it's very difficult
to find women that are totally not
threatened by you in any way shape or
from the other thing is I just think if
you are a woman or a man of value isn't
it natural that men women old young
everybody's going to gravitate towards
you and want to be around you it's a
natural consequence of being a valuable
person if I'm a girl that only talks
about hair and makeup of course I can
only have female friends but if I'm a
woman that can have a lot of different
types of conversations it's natural to
be able to connect with different type
of people